uh so we had our first trash taste panel
ever ever uh and
for the most part you know i i thought
you were it was good but then there was
some really really stand out things that
is
hard to forget about our first trash
chase experience so if you've been
living under a rock there's probably
about 30 different perspectives of uh
some dude running up onto the stage
and uh
30 different perspectives of me [ __ ]
my pants on stage
yeah i mean we weren't really like uh we
didn't really prepare anything that's
kind of nice like we could have prepared
something
like we're going to do a q a we'll just
keep it simple like how we've always
done it right yeah because we've always
done panels where it's just okay q a
easy we don't need to think too much
about it you know people are normally
chill we don't it's it's like it's a q a
you know what i mean it's like how how
riled up can fans get most of the times
but i mean the thing is with the q a
it's it's completely made by
how good are the questions people ask
yeah and you know i think it's just like
roll of the dice sometimes that some
people just asked questions that were
either just like cringy or yeah um would
ask questions that didn't really
actually make us talk about anything
it's kind of like what's your favorite
anime and it's like all right is this
okay it was kind of like there was also
like a lot of like very loaded questions
where it's like everyone knew the answer
to it yeah yeah it was asked and it's
like why would you ask a question that
everyone already knows yeah yeah
i mean i'd say like for the most part we
had some we had good questions there's
some good ones yeah yeah i think like
okay i'm going to say this now i'm going
to say this now right if you ask connor
about his relationship status just just
just stop just just
it is crit i'm going to call out because
like when we see it on comments on our
redis like
like connor's commented on it in the
past like now as a mate seeing it in
real life on stage i'm just like come on
girl it's crazy come on please stop
please don't stop
it's just a question that people always
want to know right because they're
they're like i don't understand the
curiosity here yeah people want to know
right and i i get it my my thing is like
all right
if one person asks all right i'll i'll
make some joke and and tell you to
yeah funny
i'm dating chris yeah and then it was
just like okay then someone else just
asked again afterwards and then it's
like it's like all right like did see he
just asked that like and and you didn't
get an answer you're not gonna get a
[ __ ] i'm not gonna tell you anything
like don't ask me this [ __ ] it's like oh
we didn't get a full answer what if i
ask again
it's like you know
whether i did or didn't or i i married
with four kids like
i'm gonna i'll talk about it if i want
to talk about it yeah yeah yeah exactly
you know if someone wants to keep
something private then let them keep
their privacy yeah yeah
and like let's not be confirming or
denying anything so shut the [ __ ] up
like this this is gonna be like
psychoanalysis
break down word for word
you know because it's parasocial and
ease dude i don't know
it's just what it is you know it it
sucks and i but i know it's like a part
of yeah i i guess i guess it was just
like you know we've we've seen the
comments and everything and i'm sure you
get it on your twitch chat all the time
oh yeah here hearing it like in person
like as a mate i'm just like you know it
just
i've i felt my bro man
because i i would feel uncomfortable
like yeah i mean it's happened so many
times now where it's kind of like all
right i just have the routine of dealing
with it of like ha ha but that well
that's the one thing
that's another one that i've kind of
figured out like going to this
convention doing the panel is that like
it you know because we've talked about
parasocial relationships so many
freaking times on the show yeah and it's
like you'd think that like after the
amount of times we've talked about it
people start to be like okay yeah i get
the boys perspectives on it but there's
also the fact where if you talk about
parasocial relationships it makes it
seem like okay the person listening
isn't a parasocial relationship they're
listening they're hearing but then it's
like okay but it doesn't always like
translate well yeah but also i
understand how like on the day you know
sometimes people are getting weird moods
and some things like that i get it yeah
i i will say that it was like like i
said like 99 like i met like a lot of
people there and like the people i can
respect was just like look i know you've
because you've talked about plenty of
times you know i know you more than you
know me i just want to say i get that
and
um
and i still like love your stuff you
know i still respect everything you've
done and that's that was like just a
genuine okay i met like a few people
like at the bar at the hotel who i just
had like a genuine conversation with
from like from like that starting point
where yeah where you know we acknowledge
this but i still want to get to know
this person because we're in a
environment where i can get to have a
more chilled conversation about it right
but then you
you do just get these you know one or
two maybe fans who just don't watch
trash taste as often as other people you
know right no because like especially
like
reading the subreddit and reading how
much people have like called this out
i'm just like that's that's that's
[ __ ] great yeah unfortunately not
every one of our viewers is on the
subreddit for example you know not every
viewer watches every episode uh so you
will get that casual viewer who just
doesn't know more like doesn't know
about the boundaries much like other
viewers i think i don't know i mean to
me it was like this is just all a
learning experience
like this is no way made me not want to
go to cons or anything no no no no no no
like i i just you know like we've said
this a million times but yeah everyone
was super [ __ ] nice the signings were
great yeah everyone was really
respectful except you got shot by a nerf
gun yeah
yeah that was helpful i i i wasn't there
to see you so it was because it's like
open right yeah it was over so that we
had like a table and there's three of us
i was in the middle joey's on the end
and then there's gone on this end yeah
and this end is completely open yeah so
any anyone could have walked up and like
thrown anything at guns yeah which is
just an oversight they should have had
someone there who is like stopping like
i i think i think it was like a guy it's
a learning experience not just for us
but for the convention itself
for for the convention as well so
like i remember remember the
conversation where we talked about we
don't know if we need security for
future conventions yeah yeah uh this
taught us that we definitely yeah
we definitely do need security like that
that was like a very much a big
eye-opener for us i mean uh obviously we
had uh the incident happened where
someone came on the stage who i
apparently okay so this is a whole
[ __ ] thing right you said it was a
learning curve look you said it was a
learning experience for the convention i
feel like i don't know they should know
that it was it would have been better
and to be fair they stepped it up but i
feel like it should have been there
anyway like we
practically had like
no security really for like the first
two days yeah yeah like i i think they
definitely should have had security for
the panel but i i talked to some people
afterwards uh who were working there and
they said
this is like there's never been this
this has never happened before they've
never even come close to happening yeah
there was never like a president a
precedence of this like ever happening
at mcm right so it was also it wasn't
oversight but also
we just like a lot of people just didn't
expect it because it's just never
happened before right um i mean i i i
yeah i agree and i don't want to go too
hard because obviously like we want to
go to cons again
but like
it blows my mind that you would have a
main stage event and not have like at
least one scary dude in the front yeah
just stop like you know because it's
like like it was anyone could have come
up everyone could have come up
like you know mcn haven't had like
insanely large guests in the past yeah
so i'm thinking like what do they do
well they had like tom hiddleston yeah
and it's like there's no way like tom
hiddleston could do a panel on stage and
there wouldn't be a single [ __ ]
bodyguard anyway
maybe it's just like a thing of their
like all right well we have some guests
this year none of them are super high
profile i guess we can scale it back
save some money yeah but obviously
you know yeah but and also a lot of
these cons they they know youtubers are
big they know it but they don't like
they don't know it yeah yeah yeah
they understand oh he has three million
subs but they're like yeah but we have
the guy who voices in like very odd
parents here
and i know what that is right and i
don't know who this trash guy is yeah
who's these rubbish rubbish lads yeah
who's these rubbish lads what are they
right so there's this complete like a
lot of cons do have this kind of like
disconnect between like because that a
lot of the cons are very are ran by
people who understand like older media
yeah traditional media they don't really
understand like youtubers that well they
should buy now but they don't and so i
feel like there's a lot of oversight
that happened there
and then getting to this guy in
particular who came on the stage which
was which was a weird thing because this
guy didn't do anything for like the
first 20 minutes yeah and then started
shouting he was like everyone thought he
was like just a heckler yeah yeah i
thought he was a hacker yeah because i
was just like you know we've all dealt
with hecklers
as well of course uh so you know uh
someone asked the question and then we
just i just like heard someone shouting
something in like the [ __ ] background
or something i'm just like oh okay it's
it's just ignore them it's passionate
anime fans i've heard it all before you
know um and then suddenly i see some guy
just walking up to the stage and i'm
just like is this happening i i yeah is
this is this happening i heard like a
gadget no no i'm coming on yeah it's
like what and then someone's like stood
up and i was like yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
someone's coming out yeah yeah and i was
like oh no worries security will deal
with it yeah yeah yeah
there'll be someone there yeah yeah i
was just like okay he'll get he'll get
to the stage oh no he's on the stage
well he'll get near the sofa oh no he's
near the sofa oh oh he's sitting next to
joey and then i remember just like just
waiting because you i i i yeah yeah i
assumed that there would be someone who
would have come on and i'd be like
someone's coming from backstage yeah
yeah that was like i was like i was like
backstage no i was like no no one on the
side yeah um
oh and
a good like 30 40 seconds passed where
like nothing happened like even the
crowd was like uh like is this a bit
like what's happening yeah it was so
like out of left field that i i talked
to some people and originally they
thought that it was just a special guest
that come on
a special guest
just just a bit in like the in like our
show or something and uh and we were
just like i think the best way to
describe it is just we were just shell
shocked
uh yeah i mean you know it was
definitely traumatizing that's for sure
because like that's like nev yeah as i
said it was like it was like
unprecedented like that's never happened
at like any probably never any of our
panels right yeah yeah so i like i don't
know how calm we looked on camera but
i'm pretty sure internally we were
freaking the [ __ ] i was [ __ ] myself
because i was like this dude like sat
right next to me like he kind of like
shoved me out of the way yeah yeah yeah
yeah like kind of in the middle of the
couch
and he like shoved me out of the way and
then he like you know i mean everyone
who was there sorry but like he tried to
like grab the mic off my head yeah
because he wanted to say something and i
was like uh no dude like yeah what the
[ __ ] are you doing yeah yeah and then
yeah he just like starts rambling off
about something i don't know he wasn't
even like being coherent yeah but it was
just like coming into one ear and out
the other because i was just like
[ __ ] looking around like uh is anyone
gonna do anything about this yeah yeah
like i remember like what he was talking
about was nothing to do with what the
question was asked yeah yeah yeah
completely out he was just rambling on
about something completely incoherent
um and meanwhile joey is frantically
looking around
trying to find it
felt really bad for you yeah you're like
anyone
i was like help because like i didn't
want to like
you know be the one to instigate
something right because like i don't
know
the dude might have a knife you know
yeah yeah the dude might [ __ ]
suddenly swing at me right i was like i
don't know what to do like i didn't like
push him off or anything
yeah this guy was big
i mean like you know
i'm not not saying that i would punch it
if like a [ __ ] two-foot man came on
the stage but like i'd be a lot more
likely just to be like to try and
leverage my own position
if they were if a child comes onto stage
you're like okay for the drop kick
you're in the situation right someone
comes up and like that
you you look at him you're like
if this guy really wanted a swing for
any of us odds are it's gonna [ __ ]
like really [ __ ] hurt and he probably
won't be able to punch like he he was
really tall yeah and big right so it's
just like it's you just sit there and
you're like weighing your odds you're
like what do i need to do like what's
the best way to handle this like i'm
processing processing processing because
like you've rarely find yourself in a
situation like this where you don't know
what the outcome is going to be so in
your head you're just like what's the
worst outcome this could possibly be and
how could i prepare for it because you
you're kind of in like fight or flight
mode at that point at that point yeah
and also it's like you know there was
that like side of me as well that was
like okay say for example like if i
[ __ ] tripped him up as he was like
trying to flee and he like smashes his
head in and he's gonna [ __ ] abby
heard me and like trying like sue me for
defamation and damages right like i
don't want that either so
i literally couldn't do
anything and i just had to sit there and
be like right just just praise that like
someone would help me i was just like
just hoping i was like okay you know
like obviously a lot of people like man
you should have just like punched him or
something and it's like well it's like
do i do i don't want to be the one to
escalate it you know at the end of the
day we're still on stage and we're going
to create creative classes like a month
yeah
that's not what they paid the money the
money for man it's just like you're
sitting there you have to like go
through it i'm like all right well what
does this guy want like why is he on
stage right and so i initially i was
just like okay maybe he just wants to be
funny and i was like well this is great
because
i'm i can handle cringe like my half of
my videos on my channel are like try not
to cringe challenges and like i'm fine
dealing with a guy trying to be funny on
stage i'll just out out wait him and
cringe like i know that i can sit here
and if this guy was trying to be funny
which we he wasn't but if he was i was
like it's fine i'll just wait until he
feels so unbearably awkward that he'll
just leave yeah and then i'll be like
all right good which is what i think
happened eventually but this guy was
completely you know he was not in the
right state of mind like this guy was
clearly online and he was also doing it
to a bunch of other panels as well so he
clearly wasn't like a targeted thing he
was just like going around just wreaking
as much havoc as possible so yeah what i
heard was i don't know how okay this is
this is not 100 confirmed but this is
the story that i was told apparently he
did this to another stage
after after hours after hours oh [ __ ] i
thought it was before no no no so after
ours and then they tried to get him
removed but at the time they didn't
right yeah because for some reason they
didn't listen to the person who was
trying to get him removed or something
it was like a whole thing
and then uh yeah we were told the next
day that uh yeah he was arrested
afterwards and uh i think charged i
don't know what with
uh but apparently when they asked him
why
yeah why why he did it yeah
sentenced sentence sent us the children
eyes of cringe
i sentence you for being cringy
so what are you in for i was cringing
i don't know maybe like trespassing or
something
either way i mean you know glad that
something happened yeah um you know they
they caught him in here when they asked
him why did it he said something along
the lines of uh yeah he apparently just
wanted to go up on stage like he didn't
really know who we were yeah yeah he was
just there trying to get on stage to
things yeah so it was just unfortunate
timing that it was a guy
at our panel who just wanted to jump on
stage yeah yeah yeah yeah
i like i mean yeah it could have been
anyone you know at the end of the day
we're lucky it turned out well like you
know if that guy really wanted to do
something this could be a really
different story i mean i see it as a
positive experience because it really
it's really it's uh do you want to be in
my scene say that
okay okay
i see it because
i see it as an event like this where
something this big happened and nothing
bad came out of it right it really put
things into perspective for us
oh yeah it made it so it made it
guaranteed that something like this
isn't gonna happen again because now we
are more aware of it now we're going to
convey this
to wherever we go to so i i think you
know
it's obviously not a good thing that
happened and maybe we should have been
more prepared for it but it did happen
nothing too bad came out of it outside
of aside from just a lot of cringe a lot
of cringe
and just like getting you getting his
ass flashed like in front of our face
because like he's yeah
his trousers was like
like it wasn't even like a half crack
like he might as well have not been
wearing pants it was like the full ass
crack and i was like oh god
why
why also he stank like he really [ __ ]
stank
like i was like holy [ __ ] that you like
you smell you definitely smell like a
con girl that's not a shot i just
[ __ ] hope that guy gets the help he
needs because he's really [ __ ] unwell
yeah yeah yeah definitely yeah
yeah
i don't know it was just [ __ ] you know
and it sucked as well because you know
halfway through the panel we have to
like the panel was it was going okay at
that point i'd say yeah and then we were
already kind of like [ __ ] dude you gotta
do this panel now after that happened
like pretend like nothing happened at
least if it was like you know near the
beginning or near the end then you know
they'd be like it'd be a little bit
easier to kind of just like clean it up
and get over it but it was like dead set
in the middle of the panel yeah yeah
yeah so it was like the hardest to kind
of recruit recuperating like get back
onto the floor of things you know
because i remember i tried to like i
tried to like continue the panel and all
like like the only image that was in my
mind was just that that ask that bare
ass crack like that that bare ass crack
just like hypnotized me to be like
where am i right now for me it was that
and also just like in the back of my
head being like what if someone else
also does this yeah like what if like
another person is just like well they
didn't [ __ ] do anything or now it's
my time to get 15 minutes of fame you
know i was like i was like so [ __ ]
scared for that yeah it's like and also
it was just like oh good i'm gonna see
this all over the subreddit and the
twitter feed in like 17 different
[ __ ] angles yeah yeah yeah but yeah
it was whatever i mean yeah yeah no like
again as like the silver lining is that
now we know now we're gonna be a little
more prepared for future cons and yeah
future events and stuff like that and um
nobody got hurt yes nobody got hurt
that's the industry exactly just a lot
of trauma and a lot of cringe just just
just a lot of emotional damage trauma by
cringe basically emotional damage but no
physical damage so that's good